a civilian volunteer in the northern
ukrainian city of europe on the
outskirts of the capital
journalists are caught up in the moment
someone shouts for a doctor
but it's too late for a family who'd
been trying to get away
elsewhere in the city russian shells
destroy homes frightened people run for
their lives
families and children caught up in
confusion and chaos
russian troops have not yet entered
keith but they aren't far away a convoy
has encircled the city for several days
a goods depot in a suburb is destroyed
by shelling but ukraine's forces in the
capital are undeterred and say they are
ready for the worst
our positions are prepared we've fitted
them out we're simply waiting to meet
them here
and then we'll chase them out as well as
any other units victory is going to be
ours
moscow's forces in ukraine are advancing
from the north east and south by land
sea and in the air the kremlin continues
to deny targeting residential areas but
the grim reality on the ground tells a
very different story hundreds of
civilians have been killed apartment
blocks schools and hospitals hit the
ukrainian president says the black sea
resort of odessa could be next he's
urged western powers to send ukraine
more weapons
they are planning to bombard odessa the
russians always used to come to odessa
and they felt only warmth only sincerity
in odessa and now bombs are coming
against odessa artillery missiles this
is going to be a war crime a historic
crime
this man who doesn't want to be
identified also talks about alleged
russian crimes he was working on a
cruise ship in the caribbean sea when
russia invaded his country he's come
home to fight to be honest am scared i
was scared when i made this decision i
mean this is the war like people are
dying and and there is i mean there is a
chance that you're gonna get shot or
i don't know injured whatever but
as i said now we are united and
on the same everybody on the same risk
lives are being turned upside down in
ukraine people are having to make
heartbreaking decisions on whether to
leave behind their homes and loved ones
or risk their safety by staying put when
we realized that
[Music]
the things are getting
bad
[Music]
we decided to go yvonne was studying and
working as a software engineer in the
eastern city of harkiev when the russian
shelling began he shows me pictures of
what's left of his office building and
describes fleeing during the violence
from my neighborhood to train station
it's approximately 10 kilometers
we walked for two hours or something
and
it was
really the
the most
caring experience in my life
but amid the fear and destruction
moments of resilience and joy
also defiance thousands of people
protested in the southern city of
housson despite it being taken by
russian troops last week
spirits are being tested in ukraine but
this is proof that they aren't yet
broken natasha butler al-jazeera navid
ukraine